en este vídeo vamos a ver cómo instalar
nuestro módulo de sonido en nuestra
beats y bot lo primero que vamos a hacer
es desconectar nuestra bocina ya que
necesitamos que los cables de la bocina
sean más largos ya que los vamos a pasar
por el pequeño agujero que está de la
parte superior y así poder colocar la
bocina en la parte de abajo soldamos los
nuevos cables que miden 6 pulgadas o
unos 15 centímetros de largo los
soldados en las bocinas los cables son
de núcleo sólido de cobre de calibre 22
nos pegamos para que nuestra unión de
soldadura quede sólida y el cable no se
mueva ponemos la soldadura ahora ponemos
una porción de nuestro silicón caliente
que sea del tamaño de una moneda pequeña
usaremos este silicón caliente para
mantener a la bocina en su lugar el
metal que está atrás de la bocina para
que el silicón enfríe rápido
aquí pegamos los cables de la bocina en
la base para que no se estén moviendo
por todo el lugar
ahora estamos trabajando en nuestro
botón de grabación aquí hay dos placas
de metal en las que vamos a soldar los
cables las placas son grandes así que
será sencillo de soldar esto nos
permitirá mover el interruptor de
encendido al arduino aquí estamos
pelando el extremo de los cables
estos son los cables de energía nos
perdón me equivoqué
estos son los cables de nuestra bocina
vamos a usar nuestro tubo termo
retráctil y lo vamos a poner en los
cables que vienen desde la bocina vamos
a soldar un poco los cables para hacer
que sea más fácil conectarlos y
colocamos el tubo termo retráctil encima
de esto para que cuando sol demos la
conexión usamos nuestra pinza cocodrilo
para sostener ambos cables para soldar
los nuevamente estos son los cables de
la bocina vamos a hacer lo mismo del
otro lado y los soldados ya que soldamos
los cables cubrimos las uniones con el
tubo termo retráctil la aislamos
lo que nos ayudará a evitar que los
cables causen algún cortocircuito al
tocarse ya que ambas conexiones están
cubiertas con el plástico vamos a usar
nuestra pistola de aire caliente para
encoger el plástico para aislar los
cables ahora cortamos los cables de
energía y pelamos sus extremos y vamos a
conectar el cable trenzado con el cable
de núcleo sólido de cobre de calibre 22
ya que este es más fácil de conectar a
nuestra tarjeta de distribución de
energía de 5 volts que instalamos en
otro vídeo y que pueden ver abajo de
nuestro módulo de sonido torcemos el
cable trenzado alrededor de nuestro
cable de núcleo sólido y lo cubrimos con
soldadura
deslizamos el tubo de plástico alrededor
de la soldadura para cubrir y aislar la
conexión ahora en cogemos los plásticos
usando la pistola de aire caliente y así
tendremos protegidas nuestras conexiones
ahora vamos a quitar el botón de
reproducción para llegar a la ruta de
conexión de esta raspamos con cuidado la
cobertura laqueada y esto lo hacemos
porque las conexiones aquí son muy
pequeñas como para soldar los cables
pero la ruta de conexión nos da más
espacio para realizar la soldadura
usamos nuestro cable de cobre de calibre
22 vamos a soldar lo en ambos lados de
nuestra ruta de conexión
este es el primer lado y ahora los
soldados también del otro lado es
importante que los cables no se muevan
porque las uniones que soldamos son muy
pequeñas y no hay mucho que sostenga los
cables en su lugar
así que pondremos silicón caliente
encima de los cables para mantenerlos en
su lugar pero antes de esto vamos a
probar que todo funciona como debe
unimos nuestros cables de grabación para
comprobar que puede grabar sonidos voy a
grabar el chasquido de mis dedos
ahora vamos a oprimir el botón de
reproducción para escuchar lo que se
grabó y esperemos que haya funcionado
y si lo hizo ahora sí vamos a poner el
silicón caliente sobre estos cables esto
nos ayudará a mantener los cables en su
lugar y evitar que se muevan se
despeguen y nos causen problemas ponemos
silicón del tamaño de una moneda pequeña
y la vamos a dejar secar bien antes de
conectar cualquier cosa ahora ponemos
nuestra tarjeta de sonido junto a
nuestra fuente de distribución de
energía de 5 volts vamos a perforar para
dejar que el botón de grabación
sobresalga del excel y así poder
manipular directamente el botón en caso
de que por alguna razón el arduino no
pueda encenderlo hacemos el agujero con
una broca de un cuarto de pulgada o 6
milímetros de diámetro y limpiamos los
bordes con nuestro cutter
ponemos silicón caliente en el examen
del tamaño de una moneda pequeña y de
tres milímetros de grosor para colocar
nuestro módulo de sonido aunque debemos
dejar que el silicón se enfríe unos
treinta segundos antes de poner el
módulo esto evitará que el silicón se
desparrame cuando pongamos el módulo
ahora volvemos a tomar la pistola de
silicona caliente para pegar nuestro
botón de grabación y lo sostenemos en su
lugar y es importante que este silicón
no toque el botón en sí mismo si no ya
no funcionará como debe ser es el
momento de hacer la prueba final
y conectamos nuestros cables de
reproducción
y parece que todo funciona bien ahora
vamos a conectar nuestro arduino en la
estructura lo ponemos encima de los
tornillos de metal vemos que el arduino
queda en la posición correcta cuando lo
empujamos hacia abajo
apretamos la tuerca con las pinzas de
nariz de aguja y ahora conectamos
nuestro cable de tierra a nuestra
tarjeta de distribución de 5 voltios que
conectamos en un vídeo anterior y vamos
a conectar el cable positivo de 5 volts
en la tarjeta de distribución también lo
que dará energía a nuestro módulo de
sonido en el siguiente vídeo veremos
cómo conectar nuestro módulo de sonido a
nuestro arduino para que funcione